what is rem sleep and why is it
so special maybe we can comment on that
rapid eye movement sleep
yeah discovered in the 50s at the
university of chicago it's
intense brain activity high levels of
metabolic activity
dreams in which people report a lot of
the theory of mind we were talking about
simon baron cohen theory of mind is was
actually something that he developed for
the diagnosis of
autism if you take kids most
kids of age five six seven you put them
in front of a tv screen
in the laboratory and you have them
watch a video where a kid is playing
with a ball or a doll
and then the kid puts it into a drawer
shuts the drawer and walks away and
another kid comes in and you ask the
child who's observing this
little movie you say uh what does this
second child
think and they a typical kid would say
uh they want to play and they don't know
where the ball or doll is or they
they they're upset or they're sad they
want the doll
autistic children tend to say the doll's
in the drawer
the the toys in the drawer they tend to
fixate
they can't get in on the event they
can't get into the mind of that they
don't have a theory of mind
dreams in rem have a heavy theory of
mind component people are after me
trying to get me
you can assign motive to other people
i'm afraid
but it's because there's an expectation
that doesn't tend to happen in slow wave
sleep dreams now all this of course is
by waking people up and asking them what
they were dreaming about which from a
standpoint of a ai guy or a machine
learning or neuroscience is kind of
like but it's the best we've got yes but
brain imaging
what in waking states while people view
a movie and then
brain imaging while people are sleeping
supports the idea that that's basically
what's going on
so rem sleep is amazing and you're not
going to get much of it during your
about with uh goggins but you will
afterward
why so to comment why won't i
so is it not possible to get into it
real quick
only if you're very very sleep deprived
but because you're going to be at high
muscular output
that's going to bias you towards more
slow wave sleep overall
and your body and brain are smart
they it will know they will know that
your main goal is to recover
so you can keep going so you can keep
firing neuromuscular contractions and
you can keep running
you